il y a dix ans que christophe s'est
installé sur l'exploitation de son père
une exploitation qui s'est agrandie
d'année en année avec un troupeau de 78
vaches laitières 120 hectares de terrain
et une production de lait qui a doublé
mais depuis plusieurs années la
conjoncture dans le secteur s'est
dégradée et par rapport à nos voisins
européens on a beaucoup plus de normes
beaucoup plus de charge de charges
sociales de charges patronales de
charges en général et du coup on est
plus compétitif par rapport à nos
voisins et ce qui fait qu'on n'est plus
capable de de vendre sur le marché
européen des télécoms en 2014 mille
litres de lait était payé aux éleveurs
aujourd'hui il est descendu à 300 euros
soit 30 centimes le litre des prix de
vente qui baissent mais des charges qui
continuent elles d'augmenter les
producteurs d'ovins font le même constat
il ya 30 ans quand j'ai commencé la
viande bovine elle était enfant et ont
touché 25 francs le kilo aujourd'hui on
touche 3 euros 80 cet hiver qu'on a
touché en viande charolaise comme moi
donc ça veut dire que la viande n'a pas
augmenté donc la viande n'a pas augmenté
elle a augmenté au consommateur quand
même entre en passant et nous nous
chargeons triplé voire quadruplé donc
comment voulez vous qu aujourd'hui nos
entreprises puissent tenir face à ce
ras-le-bol des agriculteurs un plan
d'urgence a été pris par le gouvernement
cette semaine globalement ce que je
retiens c'est que les mesures annoncées
répondent les attentes par entièrement à
toutes les attentes forcément mais les
grands principes que ce soit la
contractualisation que ce soit
l'augmentation des prix la mécanisme le
vin le mécanisme et en étant en marche
le prix du lait ne devrait pas être
inférieur à 340 euros les mille litres
c'est ce qui a été annoncé par les
représentants de la filière laitière
reçu par le ministre de l'agriculture